so for all the women's empowerment talk
that continues to pace like it's 1973
the numbers are really clear it's men in
this country who are in deep trouble by
every measure a couple years ago we did
a series called men in america which
explained exactly how men are falling
behind in this country we found that
important at the time it's even more
important now the numbers are even worse
finally a member of congress noticed
this and spoke to it forcefully that was
senator josh hawley he spoke at the
national conservatism conference and he
pointed out something obvious that
masculinity is under attack in this
country and men are withering and dying
as a result of it it's not an
overstatement anybody familiar with the
social science can confirm that
so over at msnbc of course they found
this deeply offensive they compared josh
hawley
of course to vladimir putin
josh hawley
with his trademark laser-like precision
has honed in on the real front burner
issue in america masculinity in this
country i am certainly not shocked that
he said something this wacky because he
said stuff like this before it's a
couple of dashes of political extremism
from a very very cynical
stanford educated united states senator
it's a dollar of the type of rhetoric
that you make here in vladimir putin's
russia that you may hear in victor
orban's hungary a
fusion of these masculine notions right
this is why you see putin posing with
tigers with his shirt off
at some point we're going to take a
closer forensic look at the personal
lives of the three people you just saw
on the screen a lot of happy
well-balanced relationships do you think
probably not
josh hawley by contrast is the senator
from missouri about whom they were
complaining he joins us tonight senator
thanks so much for coming on so you felt
moved to defend masculinity how come
well because it's in crisis men are in
crisis tucker as you pointed out i mean
listen we've got at least 16 million men
in this country who are out of the labor
force they're not just unemployed
they're not even trying to work and i'm
talking about able-bodied men prime age
men we have an epidemic of
fatherlessness in this country and
what's the less saying the love is
saying that america is a systemically
oppressive place and that men are to
blame and that masculinity is to blame
you know if you want to be a man if you
are assertive if if you're independent
if you display those characteristics
that psychologists have associated with
men for decades then you're contributing
to the oppressive place that is america
that just isn't true and it's time that
we call that out and it's time that we
say to young men in particular we need
you we need you to be responsible we
need you to get a job and you can make
this country a better place by being who
you were meant to be and we should call
them into that
god that's i mean i i can't imagine why
anyone would be anything but grateful to
hear that why do you think that triggers
the [ __ ] so much
well because the left they they hate
this country but they also they don't
believe in gender you know i mean
they're trying to do away with gender
and they don't believe in manhood or
womanhood i mean these are the same
people who are trying to do away with
women's sports let's not forget tucker
so this is a war on gender all the way
around and i think the idea of having
independent men and independent women
for that matter but independent men who
would actually go to work and be
responsible and contribute to their
families and contribute to society the
left finds that scary because those are
not the kind of people who will just be
told to fall in line by the government
and do whatever the government says to
do and the left doesn't want that they
don't believe in manhood at all they
think it's inherently oppressive we've
got to call them out on these on these
falsehoods and they are false and we've
got to call men to responsibility
for for all of our sakes men and women
need each other if one group fails
everyone suffers i mean that's that's
real that's how we're made unfortunately
maybe but it's true senator holly i
appreciate you coming on tonight and for
the
for the truth that you're telling about
that thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else